[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here i haven't
worn this shirt in a while but it's back
in the store
shop.mkbhd.com
and this
is the nubia red magic 5g it's a gaming
phone as you can probably instantly tell
just by looking at it and the main
kicker feature for this phone
is it's the fastest phone in the world
and well it is the fastest phone screen
in the world for sure that's a fact but
just in general my overall use and my
experience with it this phone feels
faster than galaxy s20 ultra feels
faster than iphone 11 pro feels faster
than oneplus 8 pro
so let's talk about it so this is a 600
gaming phone and i guess anytime the
text is sideways right away you know
things are getting serious and the
headlining feature is definitely this
screen it's a huge 6.65 inch 1080p flat
ammo led display gets plenty bright has
p3 color
some reasonable resolution and not
amazing bezels but you've seen screens
like this before but what matters most
is it has a refresh rate of 144 hertz so
right off the bat that's higher than the
standard 60 hertz a lot of people are
used to and it's even higher than the 90
and 120 hertz of a lot of the high
refresh rate flagships that have come
out in the last one to two years it's
super
super super fast and smooth throughout
the ui throughout scrolling pulling down
notifications every single little
animation
gaming everything benefits from this
extremely high refresh rate screen well
of course except battery life so that is
of course an awesome spec now if the
question is marquez can you see the
difference between 144 hertz phone
screen and 120 hertz phone screen
my answer is
yes
but
it doesn't not to pat myself too hard on
the back here but that's like asking a
professional driver
if they can feel the difference between
a porsche 911 and a 911 gt3 rs
like someone who's super calibrated can
feel the difference between those two
things but to the regular person
they're both just extremely fast so i
guess here's what i will say
this is the smoothest feeling phone i've
ever used but you notice it way more in
the tweaked animations in nubia software
than the actual 144 versus 120 hertz
difference either way i absolutely love
it because you know i have a need for
speed but then that translates through
to the rest of the user experience with
the rest of the maxed out high-end spec
sheet as well snapdragon 865 8 gigs of
fast lp ddr5 ram
fast ufs 3.0 storage and as a bonus
since you know this is a gaming phone
you got to do something extreme there is
an active air cooling system
through this phone with an actual moving
fan and air vents to keep the
temperature down so that's those huge
holes you see
on the left and right sides of this
phone and if i put this right up to my
ear or right on the mic you can actually
hear
you can hear the fans inside it turn on
and start spinning which is
kind of hilarious now this is cool
literally i guess it's a little extreme
if anything you know they'll probably be
able to say now that because of the
extra thermal headroom their snapdragon
865 will go farther without throttling
than another snapdragon 865 so that's
classic flexing in the gaming space but
there are also some downsides that come
with this extreme number one is this
phone has no chance of being water or
dust resistant obviously with huge holes
in it so it's not and number two their
placement of the volume buttons and
power button also kind of moves it
awkwardly down a little lower on the
right hand side not a huge deal but it's
true it's worth noting
and man just what a gamery phone the
whole design they lean right into it it
seems like if you're making a gaming
themed phone whether it's the razer
phone or the rog phone or the black
shark phone they've got to have some
kind of wild design elements rgb is a
requirement this phone has that of
course the logo on the back glows as a
notification light check
being accidentally really good at media
because games are media check the bezels
are you know they're a little bigger on
this phone but you do get a big earpiece
front-facing speaker and a fairly loud
bottom speaker that pairs up in stereo
to sound pretty nice and i think quite
loud and good plus there is
yes that's a headphone jack for that
sweet sweet zero latency audio what you
know about that port kids specialized
gaming buttons check nubia is giving you
these rocker buttons on each shoulder so
if you're horizontal which is how you're
gonna game you can custom map these and
so then you can keep your fingers off
the screen and map those to press
buttons that are on the screen and this
also comes with a classic special
software mode that's turned on by a
special red button that makes some
cheesy sound effects as soon as you
enable it
and this is the gaming mode where you
can go crazy customizing those shoulder
triggers monitoring your cpu and network
speed turning on and off the fan all
that stuff it's fun it's cheesy it's
it's gamery but it's genuinely useful if
you do game a lot on your phone and to
top it all off there's also these smart
pins that you've seen on the side of the
phone which will hook up to these
optional accessories including one fifty
dollar accessory that gives you an
additional headphone jack and a hundred
gigabit ethernet port so if you didn't
think they were serious about gaming now
that that accessory exists you know
they're serious about gaming now i've
also said in the past it feels like a
mediocre camera is also a requirement on
a gaming phone
with this one
i was right this is a this is a
serviceable
camera it works you know you give it a
lot of light and it can take b plus
photos that look fine and are perfectly
shareable but anything beyond that it
becomes pretty clear people aren't
buying this phone for the photo quality
this is a perfect example of where
megapixels don't mean everything you
know it is a 64 megapixel camera but it
somehow struggled pretty regularly to
capture any sort of meaningful detail or
accurate colors in any competitive way
at all so just you know what you're
getting into the only impressive part to
me of this camera was the absolute lack
of any shutter lag at all when snapping
photos zero that's actually more i guess
along the theme of this being the
fastest phone i've ever used but i think
this shutter is actually a split second
faster than the notoriously snappy
iphone thanks to the 300hz touch
response on this crazy display and also
one more thing about this camera
who's asking for these two megapixel
macro cameras
like is am i missing something you get
the primary camera you know no ois it's
not that great quality but fine you get
a camera
sweet uh 8 megapixel ultrawide camera
is sort of a fun extra it's not going to
be amazing quality but ultra wide is a
fun thing to have but then this 2
megapixel dedicated macro camera on top
of that
why this isn't the first time i've seen
this either i genuinely don't know why i
keep seeing it maybe they think it's a
cool fun addition
you know macros fun and maybe there's a
crowd out there that is asking for it
but i'm not really sure i've seen it i
would have cut this to me it seems
unnecessary okay a couple other
scattered thoughts on this phone you
know it is a gaming phone so i had to
get some gaming in i've used asphalt as
like my game of choice um because i
don't gain much on my phone but when i
did it was awesome it was super high
frame rate extremely responsive i got to
use those air triggers actually i don't
think they're called air triggers but
the shoulder buttons and it all worked
fine this in-display fingerprint reader
is
also one of the worst i've ever used in
a phone of course it'll probably work
now that it's on camera but uh i called
that motorola one and the edge plus in
that review the worst i'd ever used in a
phone this is a tie for that it's i've
never seen so many failures in one
underscreen fingerprint reader plus it's
really low on the phone so i definitely
like when they're higher up and still
easy to reach but generally i was i was
disappointed with that fingerprint
reader and then
i'm not the biggest fan of the
aesthetics in their software but
it's not bad you know there's some
colors here and there but it actually
behaves close to stock in some places
like the google discover page and the
launcher
but it also definitely has some quirks
and is behind some of the big dogs like
samsung's ui and oxygen os the
multitasking for example doesn't let me
switch between two recent apps in one
motion like pretty much every other
phone that uses the gestures uh there's
a weird bug where google photos keeps
crashing and i can't use it and he also
for some reason can't dismiss a
notification by swiping to the left
kinda like huawei's ui you always have
to swipe to the right to get rid of it
there is no wireless charging and no ip
rating like i mentioned and the
vibration motor feels pretty cheap it's
pretty bad
but all of these things you sort of know
that you're getting into when you buy
you know a cheaper
mid-tier 600 nubia gaming phone all that
being said this is still the fastest
feeling phone i've ever used so at the
end of the day my real question with
this phone is
okay now that we have this is it worth
it to go past
120 hertz
on these phone screens because you know
this one we've we've gotten all these
flagships up to 120 this one goes
marginally past 120 but like you can
imagine it keeps going 144 hertz
240 hertz
and my answer is
the law of diminishing returns basically
the payoff from 60 hertz to 120 hertz
was huge
but then every step past 120 hertz that
we go
will feel a smaller and smaller amount
of difference but they will continue to
take a bigger and bigger chunk out of
your battery so without yet seeing this
mythical 240hz phone that's no doubt on
the horizon sometime in the future i'm
gonna guess i'm gonna predict
that
just like that 4k sony phone i reviewed
a couple years ago
this 240 hertz
phone this imaginary phone will probably
only enable 240 hertz some of the time
and when you do it will probably
absolutely crush battery life
and just not really be worth it and
probably won't catch on so just like we
moved up from 360p to 480 to 720 all the
way up to a lot of 1080p and 1440p
phones and then realized we don't need
to go to 4k and found our sweet spot
i think with refresh rate we're gonna
find a lot of the same thing we come up
from 60 and there's a lot of 90 and 120
and we don't really need to go too far
extra law of diminishing returns
definitely applies so all that being
said still thank you to nubia for making
this for us to discover this together
and thank you
for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace